50 millions de francs viennent d'être
débloqués pour redonner vie d'ici à
trois ans à la grande galerie du muséum
d'histoire naturelle c'est alain
devaquet le ministre de la recherche et
de l'enseignement supérieur qui l'a
annoncé aujourd'hui une décision dont on
peut mesurer l'importance quand on sait
que cette galerie abrite dans la
poussière et la quasi obscurité de
véritables trésors zoologique aurore
molinero regardez bien ces images elles
sont uniques
cette grande nef un peu glauque c'est la
grande galerie du muséum d'histoire
naturelle comme vous ne la verrez jamais
plus tout va être remis à neuf comme
vous n'avez jamais vu c'est un
patrimoine imaginaire ce louvre de la
science comme on avait dit vieux de
presque un siècle renfermait un
patrimoine animal et en paille et de
trois siècles et demi a cumulé c'était
trop il y avait tant ferme à tous la
poussière l'oubli la pluie parfois
tombèrent sur elle des collections
uniques elles aussi commencèrent de
sabine jusqu à ce qu aujourd'hui après
un suivi de dix ans de tous les
ministres de la recherche depuis michel
d'ornano
alain devaquet sont tous se penche sur
la grande galerie du jardin des plantes
et des blocs un crédit de 50 millions de
francs pour le budget de 1987 la même
somme doit suivre jusqu'en 91 soit 250
millions de francs
le débit pour que la plus célèbre
galerie de notre jardin des plantes
celle de zoologie soit à la hauteur de
ce qu'elle renferme un joli cadeau
d'anniversaire pour le muséum pour ses
350 ans depuis trois ans déjà on a en
paille et rénover 1 millions de
spécimens
on les a enfoui dans une zone tech dans
les sous-sols secret du muséum celle les
grands animaux n'ont pu suivre qui
commencera par la diversité du monde
vivant avec on mettra à profit les
grands squelettes de baleine pour
présenter la diversité du monde marin
les grands squelette qui étaient les
grands animaux naturalisés qui jusqu'à
présent étaient dans l'arche de noé pour
présenter la forêt tropicale sur lens 8
présenté les causes de cette diversité
l'épreuve de l'évolution ensuite les
théories de l'évolution et on finira pas
d'où vient l'homme ou valeur petit de
maîtriser son évolution
c'est un petit peu le champ de la ville
nuire c'est l'univers du vivant c'est la
galerie d'évolution on passe de la
guerre idéologique a été l'évolution
voilà bien